les vidéos les plus populaires du web cd
vidéos de chats du coup j'ai voulu en
faire une
bon évidemment dans un premier temps il
faut déjà un chat non dé préférence et 1
chat plutôt mignon parce que les vieux
gros en général tournesol faut ensuite
pour filmer votre chat il faut une
qualité d'image absolument dégueulasse
alors pour ça je vous conseille
d'utiliser un téléphone portable et de
préférence un peu nul ça donne ça
parfait c'est extrêmement dégueulasse
avec un son bien pourri prochaine étape
il vous faut un lieu un peu spécial moi
j'ai choisi les toilettes
d'abord votre cheveu dans une position
un peu intrigué c'est là qu'on comprend
le principe de la vidéo ensuite on
enchaîne quelques petites actions
mignonne avec les pattes et 2 3 4 5 à la
fin faut toujours conclut et la vidéo
par un événement d'intensité un peu
supérieure un peu comme un un climax ou
un dénouement
en général c'est à ce moment là que les
gens est faux ana bien évidemment il
faut que l'aperçu de votre vidéo
s'arrête sur le chat en train de faire
une action complètement folle et le
summum la crème de la crème
c'est de mettre en titre de vidéos avec
une accroche digne des slogans
publicitaires américains chat dans
toilettes
le perroquet dit le mot bonjour le chien
dit wesh wesh la famille un chat fait du
breakdance en haut de la pyramide du
louvre
[Musique]
mais le portier bouchons
shoei police